[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom welcome to my couch pour
yourself a glass of wine and let's talk
we did a video a while back where you
guys could text me and a lot of you were
texting ideas for future videos so a
textbook kept coming through is actually
tonight's topic things that I wish
someone had told me before I had kids so
for me the number one thing that I wish
someone had told me about becoming a
mother was how it would impact me
psychologically like when you think
about having kids you think oh my gosh
I'm going to be tired it's going to be a
lot of responsibility it's going to be a
financial responsibility it but you
don't think about what it's going to do
to you psychologically I don't know what
it is about becoming a mother that made
me feel like everything all of a sudden
needs to be perfect and all of a sudden
I need to be perfect and I hold myself
to these crazy standards as a mother
because I feel like I have two children
who look to me on what to do and rely on
me and everything I do has to be perfect
I am a working mom I work full-time it's
really tough I wake up at 6:30 in the
morning I try to get myself ready while
I get the kids ready try to get them to
daycare on time trying to get to work on
time work all day try not to check my
phone too much to like deal with all the
other kids stuff try to get home in time
to pick them up make dinner put them to
bed pass out on the couch repeat I feel
guilty because I was a working parent I
have two huge responsibilities I have my
children and I have my job a lot of the
time my job takes away from time that I
could spend with my children and then on
the weekends I sometimes I just need to
spend some time staring at the wall and
they'll watch cartoons for a couple
hours and that even makes me feel like
crap and I think social media is a huge
problem when it comes to setting
unrealistic expectations for moms
because we're supposed to post
everything positive and everything good
and the second someone posts something
bad or unhappy it's like for example you
look at my Instagram you take this one
for example it's me my boys are both
smiling
and we're out in nature we look super
happy what you don't see is my husband
complaining every five seconds about
having to take a picture it's 20 degrees
outside so we're all freezing but we had
cute shirts on so I made my kids take
their jackets off and you don't see that
8000 outtakes of both of them frowning
and crying and me about to start crying
as well and of course we all know that
social media is just the highlight reel
of people's lives but for me as a mother
with so much responsibility and these
high standards of perfection it's really
detrimental in my self-esteem to be
seeing all these other moms just looking
so happy so well-rested so pleased with
everything and just like they have
everything together when I feel like
half the time I'm falling apart seeing
all this stuff is just like a constant
reminder of my shortcomings and it makes
me feel like crap
but the way that I have started to think
about it and what I've started to
realize is it's fine to just be okay I
always tell people in the world okay
aslam and I'm so happy with that I mean
you meet my kids
they're well-adjusted kids they are
clothed they're fed they're loved
they're happy and maybe they ate a box
of mac and cheese last night but that's
not going to kill them and at least they
ate and maybe they sit on the couch and
watch cartoons for a few hours but I
made sure that they're distracted while
I freaking like decompress and lose it
as a human so that they don't have to
feel the brunt of that and they don't
have to feel that energy coming from me
and maybe I don't volunteer for
everything in their school and I'm not
there to pick them up every day with
everything and maybe I don't volunteer
for their school and I'm not there to
pick them up every day but that's
because I'm working so that we have
insurance and they can see their doctor
and they can have you know all their
soccer lessons and dance classes and all
the stuff that they want to do and
college funds and I'm doing this all for
their future that's not a bad mom I'm
not the world's perfect mom because I'll
never be the world's perfect mom but I'm
okay so I don't know why moms are so
hard on themselves when really even if
you're doing an okay job that's fine if
you are about to have children that is
my one piece of advice to you and if you
already have children let yourself off
the hook a little bit and do what you
need to do to make sure that you are
happy
whether it's meditating or planting your
kids in front of the TV and sitting on
the bathroom floor eating cheesecake or
having a glass of wine or whatever you
need to do to practice self-care make
sure that that's a priority to as long
as you are invested and you are
committed and you are there for your
children we can [ __ ] up a little bit and
it's fine
parents don't have to be perfect also I
wish someone had told me that when
newborns crap it can literally leak from
their diaper all the way up to the back
of their head because the first time
that
happened is horrifying so that's like
awkward today I'm Hannah your friendly
neighborhood why mom and if you have any
topic you want me to talk about leave it
in the comments and if you two are the
world's okay as parent shout yourself
out in the comments give yourself a
little pat on the back and in the
meantime I'm gonna finish practicing my
self-care til next time
can this be a musical show no I'm just
like
[Music]